holiday tradition is back on the las
vegas strip job that's right alex we're
talking about the cosmopolitan
and the ice rink and the s'mores and the
fire pits and the
movies and the whole thing and hector
mejia yeah who's a holiday tradition as
well he is live at the cosmo
with how they're going to keep everyone
safe as they go to try and enjoy the
holiday season
hector good morning sir
good morning you forgot about the yays
hey there alex good morning we are right
next to the brand new ice skating rink
here and the whole experience
you fired pit right next to me pretty
cozy joining us live to talk about that
experience and everything you need to
know about the holidays up here at the
cosmopolitan
we have fedor bonucci vice president
here of entertainment good morning to
you sir
morning actor tell us about the uh
what's new this year
well we've decreased the capacity so
that we can keep people safe and allow
for social distancing
and other than that we've been we've
wanted to bring back the holiday spirit
to
bring a sense of normalcy to the
holidays and
the fire pits are available for
reservation
you can roast s'mores by the fireplace
and a
maximum capacity of six per fire pit to
keep it with regulations and then we
have enjoyable
uh other other meals that are available
we have beef empanadas and
uh tater tot nachos available as well
and so this will sort of be
your own little private space when you
rent it out and then once you go out on
the
ice rink only 60 people allowed now can
you tell us about the
different safety measures to keep people
safe
so we have we have cameras that are
going to keep track of how many people
are off the street we have
tvs that are monitored all over the rink
so that people can see how many people
are
in the various locations and know when
they can go on when they can
so more of an intimate feel now this
time around compared to last year where
we would see
giant crowds now crowd sizes are limited
we've reduced the capacity of all the
areas to below half of
what we had last year and we can't
forget masks are required
nasa required and the venue is is
disinfected
uh multiple times per day and we'll have
uh you know monitors making sure people
are socially distanced you were telling
me earlier
yep there are monitors around uh safety
is of a
is a utmost concern for our guests and
uh um we will ensure that social justice
practice
all right opening finally today at 3 p.m
until january 3rd
let's talk about pricing there is a
discount for locals it's 20
for locals 30 in general it's all you
can skate
we've got movies on mondays and tuesdays
holiday favorites like elf and
christmas vacation and like i said the
fire pits are available for
reservation but skating in general is
first come first serve and
it doesn't cost any money to come out to
the ice rink and
experience the atmosphere all right
fedora thank you very much for having us
this early in the morning there you have
it
reporting live right next to the fire
pit hector mejia
ain't need to stand back to you guys
that is the kind of office we are
talking about
hector always uh cool to see
when they've got the skating rink going
in the movies obviously it's a little
different this year but still as they
were talking about
a fun way uh to try and experience the
holiday season sherry i think you were
mentioning also and we've seen video
that the rink over at summerlin downtown
summerlin is available as well
yeah i saw some people skating there um
i think ted was showing people
at the summerlin ice rink skating
because there's a nice camera that
zeroes in right on the ice rink so
people are already starting to get into
the swing of the holidays nate it's uh
inevitable that people are going to
start feeling uh like
you know christmas and hanukkah and all
the holidays
absolutely and we got turkey day coming
up next week so that's going to help
move everybody forward into that holiday
feeling so here's here's the move
you fill up on the turkey you sharpen
your skates then you go skate to
exercise all those pounds off
sure yes
that's the workout routine sherry